Die NerdNews im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Danke, Merlin.
Radio hat einen Namen.
Willkommen zurück. Hier ist der Blue Moon auf Ritz heute mit dem Chaos Radio. Ich bin Konrad Spremberg und drei Menschen vom Chaos Computer Club sind mit mir im Studio. Alex ist da.
Hallo.
Peter auch. Und Danimo. Hallo. So wir reden über WannaCry heute Abend. Dieser Name ist ja auch geil. I WannaCry haben sich bestimmt einige der Betroffenen gedacht, deren Rechner von diesem Trojaner infiziert worden sind, die dann ihre gesamten Daten verschlüsselt bekommen haben und dazu aufgerufen wurden, Geld in Bitcoin zu bezahlen, um die Daten wieder frei zu bekommen. Ich hab gerade mal gesehen, es gibt einen Twitter-Account, könnt ihr nachgucken, der heißt actual ransom, actual unterstrich ransom auf Twitter. Da wird immer getwittert, wenn jemand bezahlt hat für diesen WannaCry Trojaner. Wir haben schon kurz erklärt, es gibt dieses System, das heißt Blockchain, du siehst alles, was passiert in dem System, du siehst in diesem Bitcoinsystem, welche Zahlungen, wohin, an welches Bitcoins Portemonnaie fließen. Kannst deswegen auch sehr genau sehen, was diese Erpresser schon eingenommen haben mit ihrem Trojaner. Und hier zum Beispiel kann man sehen, gerade vor sechs Stunden hat zuletzt ein Mensch für WannaCry bezahlt. Und zwar ist die Summe jetzt gerade bei, nee, es waren 34 US-Dollar. Und kann das sein, das passt doch nicht. Aber steht hier.
136.000.
Vielleicht in einem Land, wo die Summe dann etwas geringer ist.
Das war's, das hat er erzählt. Stimmt, es gibt ja Länder, wo man viel, viel weniger bezahlen muss, weil die Länder an sich ärmer sind. Okay, also da hat offensichtlich jemand bezahlt in einem Land, wo die Menschen in Dollar umgerechnet weniger Geld haben. Und deswegen musste er nur in Anführungszeichen 34 Dollar und 11 bezahlen. Kann man alles nachvollziehen. Es gibt hier automatisiert haufenweise Tweets. Vor acht Stunden zum Beispiel kam ein ganzer Haufen rein. Ist auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, um ja rauszubekommen, wie viele Menschen den Erpressern schon gefolgt sind sozusagen. Wir haben so die Grundlagen alle schon ganz gut besprochen, glaube ich. Was WannaCry ist, was so ein Pressungs-Trojaner ist und wie das Ganze funktioniert hat, könnt ihr nachhören nach der Sendung im Podcast auf fritz.de. Jetzt würde ich gerne einmal noch zusammenfassen, warum haben die das gemacht? Ging es nur ums Geldverdienen oder hatten die auch noch andere Gründe das zu tun, Leute vielleicht auszuspionieren, keine Ahnung?
Also in diesem Fall ist das tatsächlich ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil eben, wie schon vorhin erwähnt, die Zahlungen, die da jetzt eingehen, doch eher gering sind. Aber es ist bisher nicht nachgewiesen oder gezeigt, dass dieser Crypto-Trojaner irgendetwas anderes tut, als das, was im Prinzip draufsteht, also die Dateien zu verschlüsseln. Das heißt, man kann tatsächlich davon ausgehen, dass es in dem Fall irgendwie ums Geld geht.
Okay, also wahrscheinlich keine Menschen, die irgendwas wissen wollen über mich, wenn sie mich angreifen?
Eher unwahrscheinlich.
Okay, jetzt lass uns mal drüber sprechen, was ich tun kann, damit ich nicht Opfer werde von sowas. Ihr habt schon gesagt, es geht da viel ums Updates einspielen. Jetzt könnte ich ja denken, ich hab doch einen Virenscanner. Ist doch kein Problem.
Ja, also jetzt inzwischen haben natürlich die Vendoren dann auch, also die ganzen Firmen, die eben jetzt Virenscanner herstellen, haben jetzt natürlich auch schon vernünftige Signaturen, also die passenden Merkmale im Prinzip von diesem Krypto-Locker, um den halt zu finden und dann eben auch eine Infektion zu verhindern. Aber natürlich so ganz in der frühen Phase, wo das erst anläuft, da gibt es dann immer so eine gewisse Zeit, die es halt dauert, bis dann tatsächlich die Signaturen da sind, bis dann der Virenscanner da auch schützt. Und jetzt gerade so Industriesysteme haben jetzt vielleicht auch gar keinen Virenscanner, weil das sind dann vielleicht irgendwelche Echtzeitsysteme, wo das dann eher nicht geht. Oder die sind halt einfach jetzt gar nicht so als Computer wahrgenommen, sondern es ist halt diese Box, die irgendwo neben der Fräse steht und wo mein Bildschirm dran ist, wo ich halt drauf klicke, um meine Fräspunkte zu setzen. Das heißt jetzt in diesem Fall ist das jetzt nicht verwunderlich, dass da vielleicht auch so später noch Infektionen passieren.
Die Virenscanner, die können nur reagieren, die funktionieren nicht proaktiv.
Das heißt die NSA zum Beispiel hatte zwar alles, was die Virenscanner-Hersteller hätten haben müssen, um sich darauf vorzubereiten.
Wie auch Microsoft.
Wie auch Microsoft. Aber die Virenscanner-Hersteller sind nicht informiert worden, konnten also erst reagieren, als der Virus schon unterwegs war.
Tatsächlich hatten sogar die Virenscanner-Hersteller in dem Fall schon die Möglichkeiten, Teile von der Malware hier zu erkennen. Dadurch, dass dieser Exploit, der von NSA entwickelt wurde, auch schon vorher öffentlich war, gab es im Prinzip schon die Möglichkeit, Signaturen zu bauen für diese Art von Angriff gegen ein Zielsystem. Aber? Bedingt dadurch, wie Virenscanner funktionieren, kann das teilweise schwierig zu implementieren sein, schwierig zu finden sein. Dieser Exploit ist dann auch relativ speziell dadurch, dass es in den Betriebssystemen Kern geht. Man spricht von User-Land jetzt nicht in dem Bereich, wo normale Applikationen wie mein Word laufen, sondern tatsächlich in dem Bereich, wo dann die Grundfunktionalitäten von meinem Betriebssystem sind.
In Windows innen drin?
Genau, ganz tief unten drin.
Jetzt habt ihr auch schon mehrmals gesagt, dass eines der wichtigsten Themen, über die wir unter dem Stichpunkt vorbeugen reden müssen, Updates sind. Irgendwelche Patches, die für mein System rausgegeben werden oder Updates für einzelne Softwareprogramme. Jetzt mache ich es meistens so. Ich bekomme einen Pop-up und da steht drin, hey, es gibt eine neue Version, cool, installiere die mal. Dann drücke ich drauf und dann habe ich die installiert. Gibt es Sachen, die ich trotzdem falsch machen kann, wenn ich so vorgehe, in dem mich schützen wollen vor so einem Virus?
Ja, Quellen. Wo kommt diese Anfrage her oder diese Meldung her? Ist die wirklich von dem Softwarehersteller oder bist du gerade auf einer Webseite, wo vielleicht jemand Werbung zeigt, die so aussieht, als wäre das ein Update-Angebot? Und wenn du draufklickst, passiert was ganz anderes. Vielleicht kriegst du dann den Trojaner sogar.
Dein Mikrofon muss an.
Genau. Und da ist natürlich die Möglichkeit, die du hast, im Zweifelsfall alle Browser alles zu machen, was irgendwie Webseiten anzeigt. Und dann sich mal dieses Fenster genau angucken. Normalerweise, wenn man die Browser wirklich geschlossen hat und wenn man sich sicher ist, dass der Browser an sich gar nicht mehr läuft und dieses Fenster immer noch sichtbar ist, dann kann man sich normalerweise angucken, was sind das für Updates und so weiter und so fort. Da kann man sich dann schon relativ sicher sein, weil normalerweise diese Update-Warnungen, die als Werbung ausgespielt werden, die sind darauf getrimmt und die sind auch visuell so gestaltet, dass man auf jeden Fall sofort draufklickt.
Ja, ich kenn das, ne? Da kommt dann gerne mal unten rechts so ein Kasten hochgefahren. Hey, Ihre Anti-Virus-Software muss ganz dringend geupdatet werden. Drücken Sie hier drauf. Blink, blink.
Auf gar keinen Fall unter Druck setzen lassen.
Also drück jetzt. Tu es.
Genau.
Also alles, was blinkt, ist generell erst mal schlecht.
Das finde ich super. Lass uns mal kurz so eine einfache Update-Routine entwickeln. Also ich möchte mich gegen WannaCry oder alle möglichen anderen Viren schützen. Ich möchte das tun, indem ich alle Updates gut fahre. So, wir haben uns schon gelernt. Ich achte darauf, dass ich, wenn irgendein Pop-Up kommt, was mir sagt, du brauchst ein Update, dass ich checke, kann das wirklich das echte Pop-Up von dieser Software sein? Dazu kann ich alle Browser schließen, um das gegenzuchecken. Und dann noch mal schauen, sieht das authentisch aus, könnte das passen. Und wenn ich da sage, ja, das sieht mir vertrauenswürdig aus, dann fahre ich das Update. Worauf muss ich noch achten?
Ist es das?
Geht es nur noch darum, regelmäßig Updates zu machen?
Es gibt natürlich immer noch Software, die sich nicht von selber updatet. Das heißt Software, die man benutzt, die man regelmäßig benutzt, oder Software, die Dienst auch anbietet vor allen Dingen. Das ist jetzt bei Enternwendern im Normalfall nicht so, aber es gibt gerade irgendwelche Spezialsoftware, wo man sagt, hier, mach das mal, und mach dann mal irgendwie eine Portweiterleitung auf dem Router. Das kriegt man immer mal wieder so zu hören. Und dann kannst du ganz schnell irgendwelche Dienste anbieten. Und immer, wenn man das hört, das sind immer die Programme, mit denen man im Zweifelsfall hinterher Ärger haben kann, wenn die nicht auch automatisch regelmäßig upgedatet werden.
Stichwort Portweiterleitung. Da sollte man misstrauisch werden.
Es gibt ja auch Software, die man kauft, wo Updates vielleicht gar nicht Teil von dem Produkt oder von dem Angebot sind. Da auch aufpassen. Das ist schon ein wichtiger Wert, dass die Software geupdatet werden kann, dass man Updates für eine gewisse Zeit mitbekommt, wenn man eine Software kauft.
Wie war es dann jetzt bei WannaCry? Ihr habt schon gesagt, da war der Kern des Windows-Betriebssystems quasi die Stelle mit dem Loch. Das bedeutet, in dem Fall haben Leute wahrscheinlich ignoriert, dass Windows gesagt hat, hallo, du kannst mich updaten.
Genau, und Windows hat das tatsächlich in der lautesten möglichen Version gesagt. Also an so Windows-Update-Benachrichtigungen, da stehen dann immer so Warnlevel dran im Wesentlichen. Wie schlimm brennt es jetzt gerade? Und in dem Fall hat Microsoft sinnbildlich dran geschrieben, helllodernd und mit Wasser können wir jetzt auch nicht mehr löschen. Da geht nur noch Sand. Das ist tatsächlich in dem Fall so, dass jetzt alle Administratoren und alle Leute, die irgendwie zuständig sind für jetzt Updates in Netzwerken, die haben das mitbekommen. Also da gab es eigentlich keine Möglichkeit, das zu übersehen. Das wurde eben von Microsoft selber als Warmable bezeichnet. Das heißt, es ist halt eine Lücke, die wirklich dazu geeignet ist, dass sich unerwünschte Software selbstständig unter Ausnutzung dieser Lücke im Netzwerk fortbewegt.
Und geschützt werden... Also warte mal, jeder hätte sich schützen können, indem er da auf Update rechtzeitig geklickt hätte.
Genau, ja nun ist es in jetzt vier Netzwerken nicht unbedingt so, dass man direkt die Updates von dem Windows-Update-Server holt. Sondern da gibt es dann in der Regel so einen Zwischenpunkt noch, wo dann eben die Updates gesammelt werden und dann werden die eben einzeln freigegeben.
Nachdem die getestet worden sind.
Also so eine firmeninterne Zwischenschleife noch quasi.
Qualitätssicherung, ja.
Und die hat dann vielleicht teilweise zu lange gedauert?
Genau, da ist es jetzt natürlich je nach Konstrukt so, dass man dafür dann vielleicht irgendeinen Dienstleister hat oder eben einfach sehr langsame Prozesse, die dann unter Umständen einfach dazu geführt haben, dass das einfach viel zu lange gedauert hat und selbst so ein kritisches Update eben nicht notfallmäßig außer der Reihe eingespielt wurde.
Das bedeutet, jetzt gerade wäre für solche Firmen zum Beispiel zu tun, dass die ihre Strukturen überarbeiten und dafür sorgen, dass Updates schneller auf den Rechnern landen?
Genau.
Okay, was wäre noch eine Konsequenz? Also jetzt habe ich mitbekommen, ich bin nicht betroffen, aber es ist überall passiert.
Möglichst Systeme isolieren, dass die nicht beliebig im Internet verfügbar sind, dass die auch nicht beliebig miteinander kommunizieren können. Wenn man in einer Firma vielleicht Produktion und Vertrieb hat, macht es Sinn, da zwei verschiedene Netzwerke zu haben, sodass ein Problem in dem anderen Bereich sich nicht beliebig verbreiten kann.
So könnte man zumindest verhindern, dass gleich die gesamte Firma befallen ist, sondern vielleicht die Zahl der Rechner halbieren oder so. Aber damit könnte man nicht verhindern, dass es passiert.
An sich nicht, nur wenn man dann sowohl Produktion als auch Vertrieb aus dem Internet komplett fernhält oder weglässt, ist Vertrieb natürlich schwierig.
Aber das ist nicht ein Problem, was ich als Privatanwender habe, oder es besteht eine Chance, dass mein Rechner jetzt gerade im Internet ist, erreichbar ist über eine öffentliche IP.
Je nach Portweiterleitung.
Es gibt halt auch Router, die machen sogenanntes UPNP, Universal Plug and Play. Und er kann ein Programm anmelden. Ich hätte gerne eine Portweiterleitung. Der Router sagt, du wirst schon wissen, was du tust, die hasse. Und das ist also auch ein Tipp, UPNP abschalten.
Kommt auch auf die Liste.
Kommt auch auf die Liste. Bitte?
Also nicht nur eure Rechner könnten problematisch sein, vor allem könnte auch euer Router Probleme machen. Alles klar.
Genau, und die größte Problematik ist etwas, was sich die Betriebssystemhersteller gerade selber reinholen. Sowohl Microsoft als auch Apple gehen ja jetzt gerade die Schiene, für das Betriebssystem gern Geld mehr zu verlangen, weil sie andere Einkommensquellen haben. Bei Microsoft sind das die Cloud-Dienste, bei Apple ist das der Store. Und auch Microsoft würde gerne in Richtung eines Stores gehen, wo sie quasi, Moment, genau, ja eigentlich ist es gut. Eigentlich ist es gut, denkt man. Und dann ist aber das Problem, sie verwandeln ihre Betriebssysteme in sich ewig verändernde Dinge. Das heißt, bei Updates kriegst du nicht nur Sicherheitsupdates, sondern auf einmal sieht alles ganz anders aus.
Deine Lieblingsfunktion ist nicht mehr da.
Oder ist jetzt woanders. Und das ist das große Problem, damit minderst du signifikant die Akzeptanz von Updates, weil die Leute dann sagen, was hilft mir das denn, dass ich jetzt sicher bin, wenn ich nicht mehr arbeiten kann, weil ich mich jetzt erstmal umgewöhnen muss.
Noch schlimmer, deine alte Dokumente kannst du gar nicht mehr öffnen.
Unter Umständen. Oft ist es halt auch wirklich so ein bisschen so, dass man die Anwender so ein bisschen in Akzeptanz schulen muss und ihnen dann halt auch eine Handreichung geben muss. Das würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch von den Betriebssystemherstellern noch ein bisschen mehr wünschen, dass sie da eher einen kooperativen Weg gehen, als einen Weg, wo sie sagen, wir geben hier per order of the move die vor, wie die Dinge jetzt sind. Und du hast sie zu fressen und du hast im Idealerweise auch selber rauszufinden, wie das jetzt funktioniert. Und man muss einfach einen Weg finden, wenn man Security Updates und normale Updates unbedingt vermischen will, was halt gerne getan wird. Gerade für den Privatanwender ist das ja überhaupt nicht ersichtlich. Man muss Wege schaffen, dass diese Akzeptanz steigt. Und das passiert eben gerade nicht, weil einfach das Ziel gerade ist, das Betriebssystem weiter zu entwickeln mit den Updates. Und dann sagen, die einzige Möglichkeit ist halt, die mit den Security Updates zu verreichen, weil sonst gibt es überhaupt keine Motivation für den Endanwender.
Also die Hersteller hoffen, dass die Endanwender sich denken, ey ich brauch Sicherheits Updates, ich hol mir halt die blöden neuen Funktionen. Und manche Anwender denken sich, geh du mir weg mit deinen neuen Funktionen, da hol ich mir auch kein Sicherheits Update.
Genau.
Okay, und eine Konsequenz könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass die Hersteller ihre Updates einfach getrennt ausspielen. Aber das tun sie nicht, weil sie dann weniger tolle neue Funktionen anbringen können.
Genau, also letztendlich läuft das nicht anders, als wirklich einen vernünftigen Dialog hinzukriegen. Und das sehe ich einfach nicht.
Und dann gibt es ja noch das Problem, im Fall von Windows XP zum Beispiel ist das so, dass ein System noch überall im Gebrauch ist, aber gar nicht mehr regulär vom Hersteller gepatcht wird. Stimmt's?
Richtig, seit einigen Jahren schon nicht mehr.
Wobei auch da gibt es wieder Gleiche und Gleichere. Nämlich die Leute, die sich einen erweiterten Support-Vertrag bei Microsoft geklickt haben, für wirklich, wirklich viel Geld, die haben diesen Patch tatsächlich auch von Windows XP bekommen. Und der Rest hat es erst dann bekommen, in dem Moment, wo klar war, wie schlimm die Lücke ist und Microsoft sich dem nicht erwähnen konnte. Allerdings, was soll Microsoft tun? Irgendwann müssen sie alte Betriebssysteme abkündigen. Und da würde ich auch tatsächlich nicht mal die Schuld bei Microsoft sehen, sondern da würde ich wirklich die Hersteller der Systeme in der Verantwortung sehen, dass sie halt sagen, so ab der und der Zeit können wir dafür nicht mehr die Sicherheit gewährleisten. Dann müsst ihr die Systeme so und so isolieren vom Rest des Netzes.
Also zum Beispiel, wir haben ja dieses Fabrikbeispiel, da ist ein Roboter, der Autos herstellt und der kann halt leider nur mit XP arbeiten. Und die Fabrik will keinen neuen Roboter anschaffen. Behält deswegen das XP-System bei sich. Da müsste man sagen, das ist verboten, den noch im Netz zu haben.
Zum Beispiel.
Und ansonsten für alle anderen, die nicht irgendwelche Roboter betreiben, also ich meine, XP benutzen ja noch meine Oma zum Beispiel und viele andere Menschen. Die Leute sind einfach, ich sag mal, nicht so schlau, wenn sie XP behalten.
Wie ist denen schlecht da? Es kümmert sich keiner.
Wobei bei XP gibt es auch mittlerweile Pop-Ups, die davor waren, die zumindest ganz klar machen, es ist gefährlich. Da ist halt das Problem, dass die Leute das nicht unbedingt einschätzen können, was jetzt gefährlich heißt. Und da ist halt im Prinzip, das ist das Einzige, was den Leuten bleibt, ist irgendwie auf den House Nerd vertrauen und den House Nerd konsultieren. Und wer keinen House Nerd hat, ist halt völlig verloren.
Die Lösung ist halt einfach XP abschaffen zu Hause, Punkt.
Wichtig, das ist das, was der Haus Nerd hoffentlich sagen würde.
Leider, das freut Microsoft natürlich, weil so dürfen die dann mehr Betriebssysteme verkaufen. Aber tatsächlich sollte man nicht zu alte Software verwenden. Weil das war jetzt eine gravierende Sicherheitslücke oder ein großer Fehler in Windows. Das wird nicht der einzige sein. Es gibt ganz viele von denen, die wir gar nicht kennen. Und es wird die ganze Zeit geforscht, um weitere Lücken zu finden. Es gibt dafür auch einen Markt, leider.
Das heißt, wenn Microsoft bei euch anklopft und sagt, hol dir doch mal ein neues System. Die machen das natürlich auch, weil sie dir Sachen verkaufen wollen. Aber das hat auch einen guten Grund.
Auf jeden Fall.
Man kann ja den Hausnörtern doch auch noch mal fragen, ob der vielleicht schon mal von diesem Linux was gehört hat.
Na, jetzt wird es aber sehr nerdy. Also meine Oma und Linux, es wird nüscht mehr, kann ich dir sagen. Ähm, jetzt ist das passiert. Und es sind haufenweise Leute betroffen gewesen oder haben diese Meldung angezeigt bekommen. Diejenigen, die sich halbwegs zurücklehnen konnten, waren die mit vernünftigen Updates, Backups meine ich.
Mit vernünftigen Backups. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich unter Windows so ein bisschen erschreckend finde, weil man sich da tatsächlich selber kümmern muss.
Ja, ich liebe es als Mac-Nutzer, dass man da einfach nichts tun muss für.
Genau. Time Machine hat auch einen sehr vernünftigen Ansatz. Nämlich diese Backups, die quasi so einem Logarithmus folgen. Nämlich, wenn du vom jetzigen Datum, machen sie es zum Beispiel, da werden die Backups behalten, so wie sie gemacht werden. Was weiß ich, wenn du eingestellt hast jede Stunde im Extremfall, dann kriegst du tatsächlich jede Stunde, kannst du zurück. Und je weiter es in die Vergangenheit geht, dann werden nur noch täglich oder wöchentlich Backups behalten. Und die Theorie dahinter ist natürlich, wenn dir irgendetwas kaputt geht, dann kann dir das zu jeder beliebigen Zeit passieren. Aber wenn du wirklich in die Vergangenheit greifen musst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es wichtig ist, zu welcher Sekunde oder zu welcher Minute das passiert ist, eigentlich minimal und da ist einfach nur wichtig, dass du irgendeinen Datenstand hast. Und ob der jetzt zwei Minuten älter ist oder nicht, ist eigentlich völlig egal dabei. Und das ist das, was Time Machine macht, das ist das, was auch andere Backups machen. Bei Windows muss man die allerdings... Windows hat auch so ein rudimentäres Tool, aber das ist tatsächlich...
Also für Windows 7 wurde das jetzt nochmal so ein bisschen, oder Windows 10 glaube ich, ein bisschen renoviert. Das heißt dann glaube ich File History. Und das muss man halt manuell einschalten. Ich bin mir aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher, ob das so in der Basisversion, die wahrscheinlich die meisten Anwender zu Hause haben, überhaupt schon drin ist.
Ist das überhaupt wirklich ein Backup-Tool, oder ist das nicht nur das Dateisystem, das sich Dinge merkt? Das ist ja dann kein richtiges Backup-Tool.
Das ist ein Versionierungs- und Backup-Tool.
Aber festhalten, Mac-Nutzer können sich vergleichsweise einfach zurücklehnen. Aber wenn ich jetzt Windows habe, wie sieht denn eine gute Backup-Strategie für mich aus, um mich im Fall, ich werde befallen, meine Daten sind weg, nochmal retten zu können?
Externe Datenträger, externe Festplatte, USB-Sticks und einfach deine Dateien mehrmals kopieren.
Ja, aber ist ja ätzend, wenn ich jedes Mal alle meine Daten von Hand sichere. Es gibt ja mit Sicherheit auch für Windows gute Update-Lösungen Software-technisch, oder?
Backup-Lösungen.
Ich sage ganz ehrlich, Backup-Lösungen meine ich ja.
Genau, vielleicht kann jemand sich melden, der sowas kennt.
Wir haben die Kommentare in unserem Blog offen und da kommen immer sehr viele hilfreiche Hinweise. Wir selber, also ich wüsste jetzt tatsächlich unter Windows tatsächlich vergleichsweise nicht. Wie gesagt, die Systeme, die ich administriere, sind halt größere Systeme. Da haben die Systeme einfach keinen Wert, sondern da gibt es halt einen zentralen Datalserver. Der wird halt entsprechend mit einer Software, die mitgeliefert wird, die auch dann Linux basiert ist, entsprechend gebackuped. Das heißt, wenn mir jemand einen Endcomputer verschlüsselt, dann ist mir das tatsächlich vollkommen egal.
Okay, also guckt ins CCC-Blog, wenn ihr keine vernünftige Software habt. Da kommen hoffentlich gerade schon Vorschläge.
Chaosradio.ccc.de dann.
Genau. Und... Ist es wirklich... Also, ihr klingt gerade, als wäre es einfach schwierig, für Windows was zu finden. Ich stelle mir vor, es muss doch irgendeinen Hersteller geben.
Es gibt Backup-Lösungen für Windows, ganz sicher. Ich kann nur keine Empfehlung machen.
Okay, verstehe.
Genau. Also, ich kann vielleicht doch eine Empfehlung machen. Das ist ein Open-Source-Tool, Restick heißt das. Das ist allerdings dann eher für Leute, die ohnehin mehr auf der Kommandozeile unterwegs sind und das auch selber compiled bekommen. Aber das kann man sich sonst mal anschauen. Das ist github.com.
Nicht für Oma.
Slash Restick.
Aber wenn ihr mit Kommandozeile umgehen könnt, ihr Nerds da draußen, dann holt euch das.
Also, unsere Hörer sind da doch recht gut auf Zack.
Ja, die Hörer, die den Podcast hören, aber die Menschen, die jetzt gerade Fritz hören, die wollen wir auch mitnehmen. Ihr geht bitte auf chaosradio.ccc.de und findet da hoffentlich gleich ganz viele tolle Empfehlungen für euer System zu Hause, die super einfach zu bedienen sind und trotzdem alles tun, was eine gute Backup-Lösung tun sollte. Was sollte ich noch tun? Backups, Updates fahren, gibt es noch andere Vorbeugungsmaßnahmen, die wichtig sind?
Im Zweifelsfall alles abschalten, was man nicht wirklich braucht an Diensten. Das ist bei Windows tatsächlich in diesem Fall etwas schwierig, weil niemand standardmäßig auf die Idee kommt, dieses Dateiteilen, dieses System von Dateien, eine mögliche sogenannte SMB abzuschalten. Das macht einfach niemand.
Für Freigaben und Druckerteilen.
Aber es gibt immerhin da die Windows-Firewall. Eigentlich moderne Windows-Systeme fragen dich auch, in welcher Umgebung bist du eigentlich gerade unterwegs? Bist du zu Hause? Bist du in der Firma? Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo Microsoft eigentlich nachgedacht hat. Weil entsprechend, was man jetzt sagt, wird die Umgebung halt als mehr oder weniger vertrauenswürdig eingestuft. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was sie an den Anwender aber nicht kommunizieren. Was manchmal passiert ist, dass Leute sich keine Vorstellung machen. Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen, ob ich jetzt zu Hause oder in der Firma bin?
Ich kann das auch nicht sagen. Ich meine, ich weiß, wie eine Firewall funktioniert und was sie macht oder machen sollte. Aber ich weiß nicht, welche Entscheidung in Microsoft bei diesen zwei Wahlmöglichkeiten getroffen hat. Ich weiß also nicht, was ich...
Aber du sagst dann, Nemo, es ist schon sinnvoll da, wirklich das anzuklicken, wo ich gerade bin.
Genau. Und im Zweifelsfall sich auch mal da einzulesen. Auch Microsoft hat da durchaus Dokumentation. Wer verstehen will, welche Dienste und welche Funktionalität in welchen dieser Szenarien dann eingeschränkt wird?
Leider kommt Windows mit viel zu vielen Diensten eingeschaltet. Für meinen Geschmack wenigstens.
Und es geht also darum, wie ihr gerade sagtet, einfach mal Systemsteuerung anklicken, vieles durchgehen, gucken, wo man Schalter hat an aus. Und bei Sachen, die man nicht braucht, auf Ausstellen, das kann schon die Sicherheit erhöhen.
Das erhöht auf jeden Fall die Sicherheit, weil weniger in dem System passiert. Ja, ausgeführt wird.
Das ist der einzige Nachteil natürlich. Dann fallen natürlich gewisse Erwartungen wieder hinten runter. Dass mein Netzwerkdrucker automatisch erkannt wird, in dem Moment, wo ich keinen Dienst laufen habe, wo sich ein Drucker melden kann oder sonst irgendetwas. Normalerweise ist es andersrum, aber um ein Beispiel zu konstruieren, dann kann es halt passieren. Oder auch diese Scanning-Dienste werden ausgestellt, weil sich jemand als Drucker ausgeben könnte und dann Unfug machen könnte. Also es gibt halt verschiedene Abstufungen. Fakt oder Punkt ist, in dem Moment gehe ich ein Risiko ein und wenn ich das Risiko abschalte, dann bezahle ich mit Komfortverlust. Ich finde halt den Drucker nicht mehr automatisch. Ich muss ihn manuell einrichten und jeder da draußen wird mir recht geben, es gibt nichts beschissenes als Drucker einzurichten. Und jeder Hersteller lässt sich da auch was eigenes gerne einfallen. Und wenn dann die Betriebssystemautomatik, die mittlerweile bei einigen Betriebssystemen sogar ganz gut funktioniert, um Drucker automatisch zu finden, wenn das dann abgeschaltet werden muss, dann jammern die Anwender wieder.
Man kann das ja einschalten oder eingeschaltet lassen, den Drucker installieren und danach ausschalten. Drucker installieren macht man nun nicht jeden Tag. Und ja, das ist mehr Aufwand auf jeden Fall.
Aber es lohnt sich.
Es ist schlimmer, als Daten zu verlieren.
Also Backups regelmäßig machen, Updates schnell fahren und unnötige Dienste auf dem System ausschalten, sind auf jeden Fall drei sehr wertvolle Tipps, um sich zu schützen gegen Angriffe von zum Beispiel WannaCry, aber auch allen möglichen anderen Trojanern, die es auf euch oder anderen Viren, die es auf eure Systeme abgesehen haben könnten. Was zu tun ist, wenn ihr doch betroffen seid und was zu tun ist in Sachen Politik und so weiter, darüber sprechen wir in der letzten halben Stunde vom Chaosradio gleich nach den Fritz Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Das Helene Beach ist so etwas wie die Perle unter den Festivals. Vier Tage Sommer, Sonne, Strand und Meer. Also für Sommer und Sonne können wir nicht garantieren, aber für Meer. Mit Haftbefehl, S-Type 83 und der Antilopen Gang. Mit Schmutzky, Pretty Pink und den Awesons. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Das Helene Beach Festival. Donnerstag 27. Abends, Sonntag 30. Am Helene See bei Frankfurt Oder. Präsentiert von die Perle unter die Radios.
23 Uhr, 32.
Der Fall des in der Türkei inhaftierten Journalisten Yücel beschäftigt bald den Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Das berichtet die Welt, für die Yücel als Korrespondent tätig ist. Das Gericht in Straßburg habe die Beschwerde Yüces gegen seine Untersuchungshaft demnach angenommen und wolle sie zügig behandeln. Yücel sitzt seit Ende Februar in der Türkeien-Untersuchungshaft. Ihm werden Terrorpropaganda und Volksverhetzung vorgeworfen. Die europäischen NATO-Staaten sollen mehr Geld für die Verteidigung ausgeben. Das hat US-Präsident Trump zum Auftakt des NATO-Gipfels in Brüssel gesagt. Die europäischen Staaten des Verteidigungsbundes hatten 2014 vereinbart, zwei Prozent ihrer Wirtschaftsleistung für die Verteidigung auszugeben. Die meisten Staaten geben bisher aber weniger aus. Neben den USA erfüllen nur Griechenland, Estland, Großbritannien und Polen die Vorgabe. Die Menschen sollen sich gegen Fremdenhass und Nationalismus einsetzen. Das hat der ehemalige US-Präsident Obama beim Evangelischen Kirchentag in Berlin gesagt. Bei einer Diskussionsrunde am Brandenburger Tor, an der auch Bundeskanzlerin Merkel teilnahm, sagte er, man müsse sich hinter demokratische Werte stellen und gegen die eintreten, die diese Werte zurückdringen wollten. Merkel sagte, die deutsche Asylpolitik müsse sich auf die Menschen in der Welt konzentrieren, die dringend Hilfe brauchen. In der Relegation für die erste Fußball-Bundesliga hat Wolfsburg das Hinspiel gegen Braunschweig gewonnen. Die Partie endete 1 zu 0. Das Rückspiel findet am Montag in Braunschweig statt. Dann entscheidet sich, wer in der nächsten Saison in der ersten Liga spielt. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Zehlendorf 14 Grad, Atlershof 15 Grad, Cottbus 10 Grad, Lindenberg und Neuropin 12 Grad, Ludwigsfelde 13 Grad. Auch in der Nacht bleibt es trocken und klar, das Thermometer sinkt bis auf 7 Grad. Der Freitag startet bewirkt, es bleibt aber meist trocken. Im Laufe des Tages kommt dann auch die Sonne raus, bei Höchstwerten von 23 Grad in Berlin und 24 Grad in Brandenburg. Stadtverkehr Berlin. In Mitte ist die Brunnenstraße in Höhe Bernauer Straße in beiden Richtungen nach einem Unfall im Kreuzungsbereich gesperrt. In Tiergarten ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Großem Stern und Ebertstraße bis zum 11. Juni gesperrt. Gesperrt sind auch die Ebert- und die Jetser Gravienstraße. Und wegen der Kirchentagsabendkonzerte gibt es am Freitag und Sonnenabend jeweils ab 15 Uhr bis metern Nacht zusätzliche Sperrungen rund um das Brandenburger Tor. Ein unterwegs, eine gute Fahrt.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Ja Seid gegrüßt, hier ist das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Der Chaos Computer Club ist teilweise zu Gast im Fritz Studio. Danni muss hier.
Hallo.
Peter. Ach so, willst du ein Mikro haben, Peter?
Ja.
Hier, guck mal. Und Alex, hey, hast auch ein rotes Licht jetzt. So, wir reden über WannaCry heute, diesen Trojaner, der vor knapp zwei Wochen auf der ganzen Welt befallen hat. Wir haben gerade darüber gesprochen, was man tun kann, um sich zu schützen vor sowas, um vorzubeugen solchen Infektionen. Wir müssen jetzt kurz was noch nachreichen. Also wir haben gerade gesagt, es kann hilfreich sein, wenn ihr unnötige Dienste ausschaltet, die euer Computer macht. Bitte tut das nicht wahllos. Genau.
Also da gehört jetzt nicht der Windows-Update-Dienst zu und auch nicht der Java-Update-Dienst, insofern man dann so etwas hat.
Und die Firewall darf auch gerne bleiben.
Okay, also es gibt schon ein paar Sachen. Ihr soll euch vielleicht Gedanken machen, bevor ihr Sachen ausschaltet, noch mal überlegen, ist das vielleicht sogar wichtig, um mich zu schützen? Also Updates-Prozesse von Windows, von Java, von anderen Software vielleicht sowieso auch. Und Updates sind generell gut.
Genau.
Wichtig.
Wichtig vor allen Dingen.
Okay, die also anlassen und die Firewall bitte auch anlassen.
Generell habe ich im Radio gehört und haben die CCC-Leute gesagt, es ist an sich erstmal keine gute Ausrede, wenn was schief geht. Immer Hirn einschalten.
Ja, das können wir eigentlich über alles schreiben. Immer Hirn einschalten. Wenn es doch passiert ist, wenn ich tatsächlich Opfer geworden bin von WannaCry, gibt es irgendwelche Erste-Hilfe-Sets für mich? Was tue ich? Schreie ich? Renne ich den Kopf gegen die Wand? Schmeiße ich meinen Rechner aus dem Fenster?
Ja, also ich meine...
Oder vielleicht mach ich das zuerst und dann.
Ja, genau, also es hängt jetzt natürlich schwer davon ab, wie gut man jetzt vorbereitet ist. Wenn man jetzt einfach irgendwie seine Backups im Schrank liegen hat, dann würde ich sagen, alles klar, wird wahrscheinlich immer Zeit, das System neu aufzusetzen, dann geht man halt hin und spiel seine Backups wieder ein. Wenn man jetzt einen, ich sag mal hypothetisch Windows 7 hat, das ist jetzt verschlüsselt und ich habe keine Backups, dann hat man nach aktuellem Stand erstmal Pech gehabt. Es gibt zwar die Möglichkeit unter ganz spezifischen Bedingungen bei einem meines Wissens nach nur Windows XP Rechner, den ich jetzt nicht ausgeschaltet hab, seitdem er verschlüsselt wurde, diesen Schlüssel, der eben für die Verschlüsselung verwendet wurde, wieder herzustellen und damit dann die Daten zu entschlüsseln. Aber das wird sehr wahrscheinlich bei den wenigsten Privatpersonen irgendwie so der Fall sein.
Also man müsste den Schlüssel bekommen in irgendeiner Form?
Nee, wenn man jetzt wirklich seinen Rechner nicht ausgeschaltet hat, seitdem verschlüsselt wurde und wenn es eben ein älteres Windows XP ist, da gibt es eben ein Bug, das im Wesentlichen...
Ein guter Bug?
Ja, gut, Ansichtssache. Aber dass halt bestimmter Speicher nicht sauber überschrieben wird oder freigegeben wird. Und da kann dann eben, wenn man Glück hat, noch der Schlüssel drin sein, der eben für das Verschlüsseln der Daten benutzt wurde. Aber das geht nur, wenn man ein altes Windows XP hat und es nicht neu gebootet hat.
Und ist das also eher unwahrscheinlich?
Und ist das ein Programmierfehler in dem Trojaner?
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Programmierfehler in der Windows Crypto API. Okay.
Jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren. Ach so, genau. Also ich bin betroffen und habe ja vielleicht erstmal den Impuls, na gut, bezahle ich halt. Sollte ich das tun?
Lieber nicht. Wenn es irgendwie geht, einfach nicht diese Organisation unterstützen.
Genau. Außerdem hat man ja gehört, der Kundienst ist ja sowieso nicht so gut. Das heißt, es gibt auch gar keine Garantie, dass man seine Daten wiederbekommt.
Sowieso nicht.
Also erstens dem Grund, dass es gerade bei WannaCry bisher noch keinen dokumentierten Fall gibt, wo das was gebracht hat, das Geld zu bezahlen. Und zweitens, weil man mit der Kohle natürlich irgendwie die organisierte Kriminalität unterstützen würde, sollte man das tunlichst lassen. Und wenn man keine Backups hat, halt sich damit zufriedengeben, dass man leider seine Daten verloren hat.
Genau, bevor man bezahlt, vielleicht einmal kurz irgendwie so analog an irgendwie Spenderorgane aus China denken oder so, dann hat man so ungefähr den moralischen Impact.
Okay, aber ich stelle es mir schon schwierig vor, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn das passiert und ich wirklich richtig wichtige Daten mutmaßlich unwiederbringlich verloren habe, dann, naja, keine Ahnung, versuche ich es vielleicht im Zweifel doch lieber mal mit dem bezahlen.
Das haben ja auch einige versucht.
Aber es ist blöd, macht es nicht.
Lieber Backups machen vorher.
Ja, lieber vorher. Das ist dann zu spät, aber macht es mal lieber vorher.
Der Krypto-Trojaner ist ja auch nicht das einzige Problem. So Festplatten gegen Kaputtrechner werden geklaut. Es gibt viele Gründe, Backups zu machen.
Das ist eigentlich nur sinnvoll, Backups zu machen.
Genau, nicht auf Netzlaufwerke.
Oh, das mache ich zum Beispiel?
Ja, das wäre in dem Fall dann tatsächlich eher schlecht. So moderne Krypto-Trojaner, die gehen halt auch leider dann hin und verschlüsseln alles, was irgendwo auf Netzlaufwerken liegt.
Aber ich hasse es immer, USB an-
und abzustöpseln.
Ja, das tun viele.
Gut, ich würde gerne noch mal kurz die NSA ansprechen, die Rolle der NSA klären. Also ihr habt vorhin gesagt, dieser Geheimdienst war es, der das exploit, den Weg in den Windows-Fehler quasi entdeckt oder gebaut hat und der wurde von denen geleakt. Stimmt's?
Nein, also vorgeblich wurde das eben von der NSA entwickelt, um eben Spionage zu betreiben, um halt in fremde Computersysteme einzubrechen und vielleicht gerade politische Dokumente zu klauen oder irgendwo russische Panzerbaupläne. Und diese, ja eigentlich Waffen kann man sagen, also diese Teile, die zu diesem exploit dazugehören, auch damit man das einfach benutzen kann, damit das eben wirklich für einen Endanwender aus NSA-Sicht nutzbar ist. Da gehört eben noch so ein bisschen Zeug dazu, dass das eben einfach zu nutzen ist. Das ist eben geleakt worden von eben dieser schon erwähnten Shadowbrokers-Gruppe. Und da gibt es verschiedene Theorien, wie die da jetzt drangekommen sind. Eine wahrscheinliche Sache ist schlicht und einfach, dass da irgendein Analyst vielleicht seinen Host, also seinen Computer, wovon aus der dann andere Systeme gaggt hat, nicht aufgeräumt hat. Und eine Gruppe aus einem anderen Land ist da jetzt dann drangekommen und konnte die Daten darunter holen und die ganzen Werkzeuge.
Aber die Grundlage ist, Geheimdienste möchten gerne in Computern von Menschen rumschnüffeln. Deswegen suchen sie Sicherheitslücken. Deswegen entwickeln sie Wege in diese Lücken einzudringen und die Rechner auszuspähen. Und deswegen behalten sie diese Lücken auch für sich und geben sie nicht raus an Viren-Software-Hersteller, Betriebssystemhersteller, Softwarehersteller.
Leider, leider ja. Und das ist eben aus meiner Sicht nicht zielführend für unsere IT-Landschaft.
Das ist vor allem besonders schlimm, wenn man sich überlegt, dass er jetzt auch der amerikanische Geheimdienst Windows-Rechner hat. Also damit dann offensichtlich die Angriffsfähigkeit sozusagen höher priorisiert als jetzt irgendwie die Abwehrfähigkeit, dass man seine eigenen Systeme härtet. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es dann geheime Patches für amerikanische Computer gab, die jetzt dagegen gepatcht haben, sondern auch in Anführungszeichen die eigene Regierungssystem und die eigenen Bürger wurden da mitgefährdet, dadurch dass eben jetzt diese Sicherheitslücke nicht gemeldet wurde.
Sämtliche Windows-Nutzer weltweit wurden gefährdet.
Ja und letztendlich, was ich besonders schlimm finde in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man immer, wenn man Politiker da reden hört, dann reden sie von digitalem Erstschlag und weiß ja geier, was nicht alles, was da da teilweise für einen Bullshit kommt. Aber das, was halt wirklich schlimm ist, es werden Analogien gezogen, die so nicht zulässig sind. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe irgendwie eine digitale Bombe und nur ich kann sie einsetzen. Das ist Quatsch. Ich weiß nicht, ob nicht jemand anders genau dieselbe Lücke gefunden hat oder ob nicht jemand mir diese Lücke abspinstig gemacht hat. Und in dem Moment bin ich genauso verwundbar wie jeder andere auch. Das ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie feststelle, da hat wohl jemand in dem Land, dass wir irgendwie gerade doof finden, da hat es gerade irgendwie gerumst. Das wird wohl so sein, dass sie jetzt auch eine Atombombe haben, sondern man merkt es nicht. Und es kommt der Tag, wie wir das jetzt bei WannaCry gesehen haben, wo das einfach nach hinten losgeht.
Weil die ganze Welt auf einmal betroffen wird.
Genau.
Das ist völlig logisch, aber überlegen wir uns mal, es gäbe das nicht mehr. Geheimdienste würden aufhören, Sicherheitslücken zu horten, um sie für ihre nachrichtendienstlichen Aktivitäten zu benutzen. Dann ginge denen ja ein essenzielles Ding, ihre Arbeit verloren. Und eine Reaktion wäre doch dann, also sie müssten ja eine Alternative finden. Und dann würden wir doch anfangen, darüber zu sprechen, dass Betriebssystemhersteller gezwungen werden, Hintertüren einzubauen für Geheimdienste. Und das wollen wir doch bitte auch nicht, oder?
Ist auf keinen Fall eine gute Lösung.
Ja, und was ist dann die richtige Lösung?
Ich denke mal, eine richtige Lösung in dem Sinne gibt es nicht. Das ist halt jetzt auch ein eher länger zu diskutierendes Thema. Aber vor allem jetzt hinzugehen und Lücken so lange vorrädig zu halten und nicht zu melden, das ist nochmal besonders schlimm. Also das geht gar nicht. Und allgemein zivile Systeme, also ich meine so ein Windows, das ist jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie nur Panzer und Schlachtschiffe auf Windows fahren, dann wäre das jetzt nicht so schlimm, in Anführungszeichen, wenn die sich gegenseitig ihre Panzerhubitzen hacken. Das wäre nochmal eine andere Sache, als wenn ich jetzt hingehe und wirklich so Systeme entwickle, um großflächig zivile Infrastruktur auch zu gefährden. Das geht doch nicht, das ist viel zu gefährlich.
Oder vielleicht nicht absichtlich zivile Systeme gefährdet, aber dass das nebenbei passiert, das ist eigentlich nicht...
Ja, so ist es ja in der Regel wahrscheinlich.
Du sagtest gerade, wir müssen uns irgendwie darüber unterhalten, oder es würde sich dann darüber zwinglich unterhalten, was sonst passiert. Nur was wir jetzt sehen, was zum Beispiel die Bundesregierung jetzt über ZITES einführt, also das ist eine Behörde, die jetzt in, ich glaube, München aufgestellt werden soll, die werden letztendlich auch nicht viel anderes machen, als mit ähnlichen Methoden zu operieren, wenn sie verschlüsselte Chats da Inhalte ran wollen, weil entschlüsseln können sie nicht wirklich, auch wenn die Behörde so heißt. Also das Einzige, was ihnen bleibt, ist auch diese Exploits ankaufen. Und wie gesagt, dass diese, dass diese, dass die, ja, dieses Szenario, da müssen wir halt die Verschlüsselung schwach machen, dass die nicht zielführend ist. Wir sind jetzt in der was? In der dritten, in der vierten Iteration der so genannten Crypto-Wars, wo also genau dieses hin und wieder, was kann man da jetzt machen zwischen Regierung und Hackern bzw. der Netzgesellschaft irgendwie läuft.
Benutzer.
Und letztendlich Benutzern, die dann aber auch ihre Sprachrohre halt auch haben in Richtung der Politik dadurch. Und das hat sich halt gezeigt, dass das dieses einfachen, dann verbieten wir halt für Schlüsselung. Und dann ist es gut, dass das halt auch viel zu kurz greift. Sonst würde die Politik auch anders reagieren, wenn es so einfach wäre.
Warum muss der Geheimdienst oder der Nachrichtendienst überall alles einsehen können? Überhaupt.
Er wird sagen, um unsere Sicherheit gewährleisten zu können.
Zeigt mir doch, dass das jemals funktioniert hat.
Also, ihr würdet sagen, da sind die Interessen eigentlich oder da sollten die Prioritäten eigentlich klar sein. Die Geheimdienste haben gefälligst nicht so vorzugehen. Punkt.
Ja, ich finde ja.
Also so, wie das aktuell passiert, einordentlich.
Ist ja aber jetzt kein realistisches Szenario. Gibt es irgendwas, was tatsächlich in näherer Zukunft passieren könnte, was realistisch ist und was diese ganze Problematik, über die wir jetzt seit fast zwei Stunden reden, entschärfen könnte?
Naja, das ist zwar immer noch nicht gut, aber schon mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Wenn man eben hingeht und die Amerikaner haben damit tatsächlich schon angefangen. Das funktioniert offensichtlich überhaupt nicht. Eine Art internes Review von eben Sicherheitslücken, die eben für sowas benutzt werden, einführt. Das hätte theoretisch zumindest sowas schon mal verhindern können, aber da sieht man wieder, solange eine allgemeine Geheimdienstkontrolle, also dass überhaupt Geheimdienste in irgendeiner Form kontrolliert werden, kann man halt auch, wenn man jetzt solche Regulierungen aufbaut, nie darauf vertrauen, dass sich daran gehalten wird. Also dass man jetzt sagt, okay, ihr müsst jetzt offenlegen, von mir ist internen Gremium, was ihr da irgendwie habt, und wir sagen, okay, das Spielzeug, das ist viel zu gefährlich für euch, das dürft ihr nicht haben. Aber solange ich jetzt nicht weiß, dass der Geheimdienst seine ganze Spielzeugkiste rausholt, funktioniert das natürlich nicht.
Geheimdienstkontrolle haben wir jetzt auch im entsprechenden Untersuchungsausschuss in anderer Stelle gesehen, ist schwierig, um nicht zu sagen, eigentlich unmöglich. Das schließt halt auch so was mit ein.
Das heißt, alles, was wir wissen, was ich als Nutzer für mich festmachen kann, ist, ich kann mich zumindest halbwegs schützen oder vorbeugen, indem ich die Sachen mache, die wir vorhin besprochen haben, und alles andere ist politisch extrem wichtig eigentlich, wird auch extrem viel diskutiert.
Beteiligt euch, beteiligt euch in dieser Diskussion.
Ja, das kann man machen.
Das ist halt das einzige, was man wie bei jedem politischen Thema sagen kann. Geht in die Diskussion, geht in die Politik, beschäftigt euch, informiert euch. Nur eine aktive Beteiligung kann irgendwas ändern, in welche Richtung auch immer. Wer passiv bleibt, ist letztendlich dem ausgeliefert, was andere entscheiden.
Nimm Stellung, sag, das ist mir nicht okay.
Genau, und das muss ja jetzt auch dann nicht eben technisch sehr ausgefallen sein, sondern man kann auch allgemein sagen, mir gefällt das halt nicht, dass mein Telefon potenziell abgehört wird, damit irgendwelche Terroristen belauscht werden können, bevor sie dann doch irgendwo Bomben zünden.
Ja, und eben das mit dem zeigt mir, dass das funktioniert. Und wenn jetzt meine Privatsphäre verletzt werden soll, dann habe ich keinen Grund zu glauben, dass das funktioniert, nur weil ich etwas opfere, sondern da muss wirklich belegt werden, ganz klar und eindeutig, dass das wirklich wird.
Und zwar nicht hinter irgendeinem komischen Schutzraum, in irgendeinem Gremium, sondern ich möchte das sehen. Und was im Moment passiert, ist das Gegenteil. Die Geheimdienste verlängern Schutzfristen für Geheimhaltung für ihre Akten, dass man sie eben nicht einfach nach so und so vielen Jahren im Bundesarchiv einsehen kann, wo ich zumindest nachvollziehen kann, okay, da hat es funktioniert. Davon ausgehend, dass sich irgendwie in den letzten 25 Jahren nichts verändert hat, sind die auf einem regulatorischen guten Weg. Sowas sehe ich einfach nicht, weil diese Fristen immer weiter verlängert werden.
Die Geheimdienste müssten uns in irgendeiner Form nachvollziehbar zeigen, dass ihre Arbeit wichtig ist und sich lohnt.
Weil unterm Strich müssen wir noch festhalten, es ist eine Demokratie und die funktioniert auch nur, auch bei Geheimdiensten, wo es extrem schwierig ist, in demokratischen Maßstäben. Und soweit man überhaupt eine Compatibilität herstellen kann, muss man das tun und zwar eher mehr als weniger.
So, WannaCry, jetzt haben wir es 10 vor 12. Wir haben gleich noch ein paar Kurzmeldungen zu machen. Ich würde gerne vorher einmal noch dieses Thema versuchen, zusammen zu raufen und irgendwas drunter zu schreiben. Könntet ihr nacheinander, so in ungefähr drei Sätzen, jeder nochmal sagen, was ihr mitnehmt aus dieser ganzen WannaCry-Geschichte, sprich aus der Diskussion darum, aber auch aus dem Vorfall an sich, der jetzt passiert ist. Was ist für euch ganz persönlich eine Konsequenz, eine Erkenntnis? Was nehmt ihr mit? Dannimo, fang an.
Für mich war die Erkenntnis, wie schnell da so ein ausgefeiltes Programm dann doch am Start war, das Sachen getan hat. Das war ja auch, was ich eingangs gesagt hatte, mit denen die Welt nicht gerechnet hat in der Form. Obwohl Experten durchaus informiert waren, aber dass die Welt immer erst dann reagiert, wenn es tatsächlich eine Bedrohung gibt und nicht, wenn Experten waren.
Ich nehme das als Erinnerung auf Updates zu achten, auf Netzwerksicherheit zu achten, dass Systeme wirklich nicht mehr Zugriff oder Dienste offen haben, was sie tatsächlich brauchen.
Gut, ich denke mal, was bei Danimo auch schon so durchklang, dass ein wichtiger Fakt einfach ist, wenn es so Leaks gibt, wo im Wesentlichen nutzungsfertige Exploits drin sind, dass es nicht unwahrscheinlich ist, dass irgendwelche Kriminellen auf die Idee kommen, das zu verwenden, um halt irgendwie monetäre Gewinne zu erzielen, also Ransomware oder ähnliche Kampagnen zu fahren.
Früher oder später.
Wenn es ein Loch gibt, wird das Loch benutzt werden. Sehr wahrscheinlich.
Auf jeden Fall, würde ich sogar sagen. Ob man es mitkriegt, ist eine ganz andere Frage.
Gut, lass uns damit den WannaCry-Sack zumachen. Ihr drei seid vom Chaos Computer Club und ihr möchtet gerne noch ein paar Bekanntmachungen hier machen.
Genau. Und zwar sind ein paar Dinge passiert seit dem letzten Chaos Radio. Wir haben uns nämlich für eine neue Location entschieden für unseren alljährlichen Kongress. Der war ja die ganzen letzten Jahre, nachdem wir aus Berlin weggezogen sind, in Hamburg im Kongresszentrum. Das wird leider gerade umgebaut. Und deswegen findet man uns, wer gerne da teilhaben möchte, ab dem 27. Dezember in der Messe und Kongresszentrum Leipzig. Leipzig?
Karten gibt es schon?
Nee, Karten gibt es noch nicht, aber ich würde empfehlen, schaut euch schon mal um. Ihr wisst ja ungefähr, ab dem 27. bis zum 30. ist das Event. Schaut euch schon mal nach Hotels um, die werden schon mitunter etwas knapp.
Ja, aber schön, Leipzig finde ich schön.
Ja, ist auch von hier gut erreichbar.
Gute Wahl.
Funktioniert. Und eine zweite Sache ist, es gibt für alle Damen, Frauen und die sich als solche fühlen, jetzt einen extra Hackspace in Berlin. Das ist eine relativ neue Sache. Gab es auch vorher schon, aber die haben jetzt wirklich eigene Räumlichkeiten. Wer da mal nachschauen will, besucht den Heart of Code. Die haben jetzt, wie gesagt, eigene Räumlichkeiten auch in Kreuzberg.
Heart of Code, ein Hackerinnen-Space quasi. Sehr coole Leute übrigens. Die haben wir auch auf Fritz schon im Interview gehabt, geht da gerne vorbei auf jeden Fall.
Am Wochenende eröffnet worden.
Und für die jüngeren Zuschauer, es ist jetzt wieder Jugendhackt, schaut mal auf Jugendhackt vorbei. Wir sind jetzt zum Beispiel in Hamburg.
Nicht in Leipzig. Diesmal in Hamburg.
Diesmal in Hamburg. Gibt es aber auch in ganz vielen anderen Städten, schaut euch mal auf der Webseite von Jugendhackt um. Und die Idee ist, dass dort Jugendliche und auch sogar Kinder unter Anleitung von Leuten, die sowas schon länger machen, mit Hard- und Software Dinge basteln können. Es gibt also Projektvorschläge. Es können auch Leute mit eigenen oder die Leute können auch mit eigenen Vorschlägen kommen, was sie denn bauen möchten und werden dann ein bisschen beraten, ob das realistisch ist und wie man das am besten machen kann. Und es macht jede Menge Spaß. Es ist ein Wochenende, in dem man einfach mal so seinen inneren Geek ausprobieren kann.
Da kann man auch sehen, was die letztes Jahr gemacht haben.
Gibt es übrigens auch auf media.ccc.de.
Und dann ist heute nicht nur Himmelfahrt, es ist noch ein Feiertag.
Es ist noch ein Feiertag. Es ist Tower Day.
Muss jetzt aber trotzdem kurz erklären.
Muss ich trotzdem kurz erklären. Es gibt den Anhalter, der Anhalter durch die Galaxis, von Douglas Adams. Der ist jetzt leider schon vor 16 Jahren und zwei Wochen von uns gegangen. Aber dieser Tower Day, den gibt es schon relativ lange. Und da tragen Anhänger dieses Werkes immer ein Tuch um den Hals oder mit sich rum. Und das hat folgende Bewandtnis, der Protagonist sagt in Anhalter durch die Galaxis, dass ein Handtuch so ziemlich das Nützlichste ist, was man auf Reisen mit sich führen kann.
Kann man schon mal so postulieren.
Also wenn ihr Leute, wenn ihr Leute seht heute, die mit dem Handtuch rumgerannt sind, aber gar nicht so ausgesehen haben, als ob sie jetzt einen Marathon gelaufen wären, die erinnern euch daran, lest das vielleicht mal.
Oder die kamen im Bollerwagen vom See, ist auch eine Möglichkeit. Das kann auch sein, dass sie Douglas Adams zelebrieren wollten. Das war das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Ich sage herzlichen Dank an Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Peter ebenfalls vom CCC.
Vielen Dank, ciao.
Alex war auch dabei.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und die ganze Rutsche gibt es wie immer auch im Podcast. Ich würde gerne schließen mit den Worten I wanna cry. Es gibt Musik jetzt von Tracky Birthday Website. Tschüss.